أه دكتور فينوكور ، لقد ناقشنا أنا
وأنت أم كوفيد خلال فترة وجودنا معها والآن
نسمع عن شيء يسمى
جدري القرد ليس قريبًا على الإطلاق من كوبين ، فأنا
أقول فقط هل هذا شيء آخر
يدعو للقلق بشأن الأطباء يقولون لا ولكن
صحة العالم
تراقب المنظمة بعض الحالات بشكل صحيح ،
نعم ، أعني أنني لن أصاب بالذعر من أنها
ستصبح وباءً أه تعلمون أن
أواني القرود هي
تسمية خاطئة قليلاً في الخمسينيات من القرن الماضي ، وقد تم تسميتها
بسبب تفشي المرض في
البحث  القرود ولكن في الواقع
القوارض الصغيرة يمكن أن تكون خزانًا وقد أتت
إلى الغرب في الماضي مع تعرض أه
للحيوانات التي ربما أتت من إفريقيا
كانت هناك حالة في ميشيغان أه
أن كلاب البراري الأليفة قد اصطدمت بها
وأه لكنها تخلق جدريًا ولكن بين
إن انتقال العدوى من إنسان إلى إنسان ، والحمد
لله ، هو أقل احتمالية بكثير من
الإصابة بالجدري ، ولكن يمكن أن تكون
قطرات تنفسية ولكن ليس بالطريقة التي نرغب بها ،
فهي خفيفة جدًا ويمكن أن تنتقل إلى أي
مكان قريب جدًا ، لذا يجب أن تكون في حالة
جيدة جدًا.  تواصل مع شخص لديه
أو كان على اتصال مع
سائل جسمه أو سائل نفطة من
أنه ليس معديًا ولا داعي للذعر
ولكن عادة
ما تعرف ما حدث في
ماساتشوستس جاء رجل في كندا
و  لقد كان قادمًا من كندا وكندا
بها المزيد من الحالات ولكن في بعض الأحيان
يحدث تفشي المرض في الغرب ولكنه لن يكون
وباءً في هذه المرحلة ، نعم وهو
فيروس في نفس عائلة الجدري
لذا يقولون أن اللقاح فعال بنسبة 85
هناك دكتور ليفانوكا دائما من
دواعي سروري شكرا لك